I've always been a dedicated and
compliant toothbrush ER but I was never
really encouraged to floss a few years
ago I wouldn't see my dentist and he
said to me listen your teeth are fine
but you need to start flossing okay I
said no problem how hard can flossing be
I got all the kits I bought all the tape
the sticks everything day one I did it
day two I did it day three I didn't do
it and then the days turned into weeks
and the week's turned into months and I
was back at my dentist again he told me
I needed to floss so I'm not as I did
some nights I didn't there were so many
excuses I'm tired it's boring I'm gonna
punch myself in the face again by
accident but now I'm a dedicated flosser
so what changed
Shaun cofee author of the best-selling
book seven Habits of Highly Effective
People one said depending on what they
are our habits will either make us or
break us we become what we repeatedly do
some of these habits are helpful and
healthy and some not so good but what
they all have in common is that we're
unaware we're doing them because they
become automatic and repetitive our
habits combine like steps on a journey
in life they determine our direction and
that's pretty scary because they're
doing most the time we're not really
consciously in control of them so why
are habits so difficult to break a new
one so difficult to make neuroscience
tells us our brain set up things called
habit loops these habit leaves consists
of three stages Stage one is a cue this
is a trigger
it could be from your external
environment or your internal environment
for example your emotional states Stage
two is a routine behavior if the action
you take in response to that cue Stage
three is the reward so the release of
dopamine in the brain a neurotransmitter
associated with feelings of pleasure
because you've had that release of
dopamine which has made you feel good
you're more likely to repeat that
behavior in response to the cue next
time and that's why habit is hard to
break and hard to make because those
neural connections are strong but the
good news is nothing's set in stone
breaking old habits are making new ones
can be done but it takes an
extraordinary amount of self-awareness
efforts so here are some top tips to
help you through it and it may even save
your gums at the same time it worked for
me tip 1 find your motivation why do you
want to change what are the benefits
what are the repercussions if you don't
change that habits and do you want those
repercussions write them down and read
them often tip 2 be specific what
exactly do you want to achieve and how
are you going to do it make space and
time in your diary to put the effort
towards changing that habit take
practical steps that will help you break
that cycle of cue and response tip 3
small steps are better than giant leaps
try the 1% idea where each day you
improve or change something by 1% that
way you start to see progress and you're
not put off by failure tip 4 don't stop
when you're on a roll and celebrate your
success keep the momentum of that new
habit going however smaller is the
continuous nature of changing something
about your behavior or signal to your
brain that this is an important change
and one that you need to continue chart
your progress and celebrate your
achievements with a treat so you still
get that dopamine hit tip 5 be patience
but a study in 2009 showed that on
average it takes 66 days to form a new
habit with some easier habits being
formed in 18 days and some hard ones
being formed in 254 days so changing
habits can change your life I think that
once you notice habit is unhelpful and
you know why you want to change it and
really the rest is a piece of cake so
good luck
go forth and break some habits thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon